[Music]
hello my name is michael crapon
i'm the co-founder of a think tank in
washington
called the stimson
center and i've worked on nuclear issues
for quite some time
for several decades
i've written a book about
the arms competition in arms control
it's called winning and losing the
nuclear piece
i say this by way of introduction
because i've been asked to talk to you
about that truth
about the nuclear threat
there are many truths
about the nuclear threat
but i'm going to give you some headlines
that most of us can agree on
at least it's hard to argue with them
and i'm going to headline them for you
in bold letters so the first bold
statement
is that the nuclear threat is real
it's not imaginary
it's all too real
video games and movies and social media
of varying kinds tend to make this
escapism
but i have trouble with escapism when it
comes to
nuclear danger which is very real
it's real because
two major powers
in the world
do not feel comfortable with
and would like to change the status quo
so that's dangerous
russia and china
would like a different
status quo
than the one that exists today
and there are dangers inherent in
changing the status quo
dangers are real because
there are border skirmishes
between nuclear-armed states
they happen
between india and pakistan between
india and china
so there are dangers in that
and danger exists in nuclear warfighting
plans
and doctrines for use
if you possess nuclear weapons you have
plans to use them
and those are very very dangerous
so here's my
second
headline in bold
while nuclear danger is real it is not
going away
not anytime soon
every state that possesses nuclear
weapons
is replacing old stuff
with newer stuff
nobody is standing pat
you've probably heard a fair amount
about some of the new stuff
these things called hypersonic
missiles
there are press reports that russia used
sung with conventional warheads
in the uh war against ukraine
but
these weapons
in my view are not
going
to play a very
outsized role in our nuclear future
and the reason is that the old stuff
works perfectly well
and the old stuff
also travels at hypersonic speeds
it's damn near impossible to stop the
old stuff
delivered by land-based missiles or by
submarines at sea
especially if the shooter
really wants to get through
has the money to get through
and has the technical expertise to get
through so these
hypersonics that you keep hearing about
and may well be worried about
they'll be part of our future but
they're going to be a niche
weapon the new stuff will just be better
versions of the old stuff for the most
part
nuclear danger is not going to go away
anytime soon
because the possessors
feel very comfortable
with their possessions
they feel very uncomfortable
with letting them go
you know
getting off the nuclear weapons habit
is different
than
stopping
smoking
you can go cold turkey
from
the nicotine habit
but you can't
go cold turkey with nuclear weapons
unless other folks join you
and this is a very complicated
very complicated orchestration
the diplomacy
has to be superb the timing has to be
right
to make great strides
and there have been great strides
but going to zero is a really hard
problem
here's my third
headline for you in bold
while the nuclear danger is real
and not going away
it's usually overblown
now
that may come
as a bit of a surprise
to some of you
but the nuclear danger is overblown
because both
deterrent strategists
and arms controllers
uh are in the business
of
accentuating these threats
and
don't get me wrong there's absolutely no
reason for complacency
this work has been my career because
it is dangerous stuff
and
it can be the ruination
of human
animal and plant life
so
it is worth worrying about
but
we've got history on our side
and i i'd like you to
take this thought away with you
whenever you're feeling extremely
anxious
about nuclear danger
these weapons were used to end a world
war
a world war in which somewhere between
50
and 75 million people lost their lives
these weapons have not been used in
battle ever since
we've gone three quarters of a century
without battlefield use
now think about that
they've been
around
125
000
nuclear weapons
manufactured
since
1945
not
one
has been used in warfare
what explains this
amazing
history
history that previous generations
found inconceivable
but found themselves relying upon
one war after another
one
god-awful crisis after another
one close call after another
nobody
no national leader
push the button
why
why
was it
plain dumb luck
was it uh divine intervention
i'm not discounting either one
deterrence is part of the answer
i'll grant deterrent strategists that
but it's only part of the answer
because
this business of if you strike me
i'm going to strike you back
only twice as hard
deterrence is dangerous
it's
purposefully dangerous otherwise it
doesn't deter
and so that's why we see
modifications
strengthening measures of deterrence
that sharpen threats
deterrence alone points toward use
it doesn't entirely explain
non-use
for three quarters of a century
for this we have arms control to think
deterrence
needs arms control to succeed
because arms control is about
reassurance
it's not about sharpening threats
it's about opening lines of
communication
the first lines of real communication
between washington and moscow
in the cold war
happened through arms control
through negotiations
which were extremely awkward at the
beginning
arms control isn't just about
communications
it's about stopping
dangerous military practices
and the very first dangerous military
practice
that arms control stopped
was nuclear testing in the atmosphere
it was
there were so many tests
in the atmosphere
at test sites
in colonial possessions
in out of the way places not in my
backyard
north africa
the south pacific
australia
kazakhstan
so many other places
soviet union in the united states
people were severely punished by nuclear
testing and it stopped
didn't stop because of deterrence
if deterrence had held swear we would
have kept testing
it stopped because of arms control
and one agreement led to the next
because that is the
is the ideal
outcome
or process
i should say
of arms control you stop nuclear testing
in the atmosphere
you stop it above certain yields
underground
you arrange for verification
monitoring
mechanisms
so you can tell the yields of
underground tests
then you stop the tests all together
which happened in 1996.
now you're going to hear all kinds of
concerns that maybe somebody cheated
here or somebody cheated near
at extremely low yields
yields so low they don't even shake
seismometers
nuclear
testing amongst all
major and regional powers
has stopped
and has stopped for over two decades
there's one outlier left
that's north korea
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas